GAMING !
Ça a tant brusqué mon corps cette petite cascade improvisée.
Mais qu'en est-il de celle là ?
Je vous ai gracieusement offert une chaîne secondaire avec que du gaming dessus mais ça ne vous suffit pas !
Le soir en me baladant sur les commentaires de mes vidéos
pour lire les retours de ma communauté
qui est la meilleure communauté du monde
je vois certains qui, avec regret, annoncent qu'il manque du gaming
qu'il n'y ait même plus de gaming sur cette chaîne youtube.
Pourquoi ai-je arrêté de faire du gaming ?
Car je suis une merde sur les jeux,
une merde colossale,
titanesque
okay ?!
Sur une échelle de Mcfly et Carlito à Gotaga, je suis sous Mcfly et Carlito, je vous jure j'ai régressé mon gars, la nouvelle
vague là les gens qui ont 12 ans qui arrivent sur Fortnite et qui font 28 top 1 par jour les gars, laissez-moi en faire un !
Laissez-moi en faire juste un ! ça fait des mois que je n'ai pas fait un top 1 !
J'ai moins confiance en moi j'ai une perte de confiance en moi depuis ça, vraiment, donc je ne joue plus, c'est un moment de souffrance
c'est devenu un moment de souffrance mais je veux bien
Essayer une dernière fois sur cette chaine
J'ai créé un nouveau concept pour cela
qui s'appelle le
"tu meurs, tu change de battle royale"
Voilà, comme ça je peux pas mettre la faute sur le jeu dire qu'il est nul etc, non, je
change de jeu à chaque fois ! Si j'arrive pas à faire top 1, c'est que je suis une merde qu'il faut que vous l'admettiez tout comme
moi j'ai mis un peu de temps à l'admettre et qu'on passe à autre chose qu'on tourne la page. J'ai mis
6 Battle Royale de côté il n'y a ni Pubg
ni Fortnite dedans je vais jouer au six ! J'ai donc 6 chances pour faire top 1 aujourd'hui sous vos yeux et pour continuer le
gaming sur cette chaîne Youtube. Vous savez tous très bien que je les ferai pas, la différence c'est que moi j'ai aucun problème avec le fait que
je les ferai pas mais vous, vous aviez tellement confiance en moi, vous me suivez depuis si longtemps, vous m'avez vu jouer à tant de jeux que
vous vous attachez à ça.
Le skill
laissez-le, il est allé ailleurs, il a rejoint d'autres gens, il ne veut plus de nous alors laissons le en paix
J'ai le seum !
Commençons avec le Battle Royale à la mode :
Apex
Legends !
J'ai jamais fait une putain de game de jeu mais j'ai fait le tuto pour pouvoir jouer. Sachez que mon pull s'ouvre grâce aux
fermetures, à tout moment j'aère mon corps,
Ok ?
C'est un très petit teasing pour quelque chose qui aura un grand impact durant toute cette vidéo sachez le. Aller on joue, on y va
cash, je vais prendre lui ! J'ai vu Gotaga qui jouait lui alors je vais prendre lui !
J'ai le même comportement qu'a un enfant de 12 ans qui reguarde du gota c'est bon pour vous?
Mec c'est ma première game tu va m'aider durant cette épreuve?
YES je m'suis fais un pote !
Je suis très heureux de jouer avec vous aujourd'hui
j'espère qu'on va tout donner et qu'on va les NIQUER
Ils sont beaucoup moins optimiste que moi ok Ozkey  s'est clairement toi  qui va nous carry c'est clairement toi
On me dit souvent que j'ai la voix d'Omar Sy  je sais t'inquiète
Mais v.. mais je connais pas le jeux!
c'est horrible... :'(
on va où? go marché, go, marché!
c'est où le marché, c'est où?
c'est où?
on est beau les gars on est beau on est beau
J'ai une grenade hein , oh j'ai un gun
je mets le leurre devant hein comme ça on est bien nous derrière
hein
ok.
C'est avec eux que je faire top 1 il y aura pas besoin de lancer les autres les gars
hola attend on va t'aider
Il a mis une bête de gre
Non les gars je vous aime, courage vieux
NAAN JE VOUS AIMAIT
Vous étiez la meilleure squad du jeu, je suis vraiment triste ils étaient super cool, oh putain il me faut de l air
J'ai trop triste pourquoi je me suis mis cette contrainte à chier quoi?! eh ben moi je suis originale que les autres parce que
quand je meurs je change de br ok c'est parti pour le 2e batle royal farming simulator
Let's go !
oh putain! quoi, je dit ou j'apparais?
eu...à Artaud City. attend Je doit choisir quoi ? si j'ai glider un bmx ou un grappin, ah bah un grappin DIRECT
tu veut un bmx ou un grappin ? Hmm *petit rire*
oh On commence avec un pompe c'est agréable ça commence plutôt bien il faut le souligner
ça ça me plait sa on va charger immédiatement je sais pas quelle arme bien quel arme est pas bien sachez le
hein! sa tire les premières balles je vais aller là bas, faut que j'aille la bas
~la bas~
vas-y j'y vais niquer sa mère, on a qu'une vie
réception sur le parasol il escalade la clôture il se dirige attend le grappin c'est le moment de tester
Je suis en infraction total
T'es mort ! T'es mort ! T'es mort !
Oh pas mal la grotte !
il est en bas, Croatie je le tue
C'est ça qu'on veut ! C''est Squeezie qui l'a tué ! Il va mal dormir pendant des semaines
Je lui ai mis 0 balle je suis vraiment un pauvre type j'ai un problème dans les jeu j'ai une visibilité très réduite en fait j'ai vraiment
des problèmes de personnes âgées alors je ne suis pas âgé c'est un vrai problème dans ma vie
Attends attends y'a embrouille là  y'a embrouille là
Il m'a mis archi mal
NON
NOOOOOOOOOON la méduse sur la teeeeeeete
Putain de meeerde ça va si vite oh je suis vénèèèère
Ce pull n'a aucun sens ce pull a moins de sens que cette vidéo
Ok c'est parti ça joue 7 "alive" vous m'avez mis dans une game où il ya 7 mec en vie ?
non c'est un sketch en fait personne de jouer à ce jeu ah non c'est le prêt
C'est le lobby avant que la game se lance bon je suis un
demeuré alors on va aller là à là c'est bien là Bychki je connais bien
Il me suit pas put*in ! il faut... Allez vas-y c'est pas grave
Il faut Une hache putain
Mais je la trouve où ta hache moi ?
Oh j'ai la hache ! Hop là c'est à moi tout ça c'est à moi voilà oh mais il est d'aucune aide mais regardez le
Ok j'ai trouvé une carte qui va m'amener à un
coffre aux trésors est ce que j'aime l'argent oui vous le savez vu les op que je fais alors je vais y aller
attends
Je suis trop fort mec en fait je veux juste aller prendre mon coffre je prends mon coffre
le mec je vais l'ignorer pourquoi je perds de la vie ? ho Je suis zones radioactives faut que loot vite faut que je loot vite vite vite vite vte!
yes merci faut que je me casse c'est quoi ce délire de
radioactivité là ils sont partis en couille mec les dev' non pas t'es mort si jamais non pas t'es morts mais bon ct previsible
est-ce que je joue avec des bots ça se trouve je joue tout simplement avec des bots ça expliquera tout
c'est quoi ça aussi?!
tiens tu m'as pas toucher t'es deg' hein? petite merde va! hein! petite merde de campeur va! moi je vais te trouver mon gars
et tu sait pas combien de top 1 j'ai fait ce mois-ci! 0 absolument 0
yolo! le premier duel il met en pls le premier duel même en pls l va me niquer
Je me casse adrenaline invection dans 14 secondes c'est quoi dans ma zone la ou je suis là je comprends rien!
a part qu'y a un mec la et qu'il est mort
Attend
Tout ça pour ça? vraiment là?
T'facon c'était de la merde ce jeux, voila, c'est bon c'est clair?
Oh putain il me plaît celui la! il est beau, il est fluide
j'adore! je vous jure je le sens mega bien
ce...cette game, et y aura pas un cut d'un coup avec moi qui meurt ça n'arrivera pas pas sur ce jeu là
g cru qu'il y avait un ennemi
mais y a un ennemis?!
mais il est la!
Je vais
niquer ses morts,en tout cas j'ai fait un kill pour moi c'est un top 1. est ce que j'ai le droit de dire ça ou
est-ce que c'est trés défaitiste? a d'abord y a un truc qui m'inquiète c'est que le gars je l'ai tuer très très vite! il va m'arriver la même
chose la
y a des bruits de poils!
Ciao mon pote
oh là là ce que je lis mis ce pauvre type! mec, qu'on n'est plus de 17 à temps mais je me régale sur ce
jeu est ce que c'est parce qu'il est vraiment bien où est ce que c'est parce que les gens sont nulles et du coup moi
je me sens fort et du coup j'aime le jeu? a... peut-être un peu des deux ma foi
attend y'a des gens pas loin en fait du tout faut que sois bon je fais les attentes d'air une maison ils seront pas
y'a un mec là bas
C'est bon j'ai fait ça mais pourquoi il n'a pas réagi il avait peut-être pas de snipe le pauvre il était en galère
oh mon pauvre type on est 8 la c'est les 8 meilleurs joueurs qui sont là je vous jure ce battle royal a un potentiel incroyable
y'a un mec la
nan nan c'est pas juste
c'est pas juste
yes, sa c'est juste sa c'est TREEES juste
putin mec!
tout ce qu'il a ce batard!
j'ai jamais vu un gars qui avais autant de stuf de ma viiie
mec c'est bon!
on a une passoire sur la tête gros!
meilleure béère de l'année!
Arrête avec cette musique qui a pour but de stresser
ELLE N'A AUCUNS EFFETS SUR MOI
TU VOIS PAS QUE SA MARCHE PAS?!
ALORS COUPE LA
surprise...
MOTHER F***ER
merde...
il a sauter la ce chien
Pas comme ça
très bon jeu!
on en parle de ce jeu?
qu a été fais pour un premier avril et qui est juste trop bien!
j'ai a-doré
jusqu''a cce que ce... ce gros CONNARD de ses morts me tue bien sur
Tu ne feras jamais top 1
tu ne feras jamais top 1
1...
Le cinquième jeux ne marche pas les serveurs sont dawn
est ce un signe du destin ou simplement une coïncidence?
c'est pas la réponse à cette question et c'était le passage de plus chiant de la vidéo alors je m'en excuse allez on y va
Il est temps de jouer à apex
et non pas à pécs
ce qui serait bien moins drôle
je suis en battle royale nawt
c'est quand tu fais un burn auwt parce que tu as trop jouer
au battle royale
et surtout trop perdu!
C'est maintenant il y aura-t-il encore du gaming sur cette chaîne c'est maintenant je dois le mériter en être capable
alors vais-je faire ce putain de top qui va à jamais marqué le youtube game français voire mondial
je suis fatigué allez faisons top 1 aller!
oh un pack a ouvrir
attend...est-ce bon signe? c'est bon signe sa!
Celle là c'est la bonne, celle là c'est la nôtre
statistiquement stephen hawking la prouver sur 30000 game de battle royale vous ferez un top 1 minimum c'est la 30 millième c'est maintenant
C'est maintenant il ya juste une squad qui a mieux géré son atterrissage que nous mais c'est maintenaaaaannnnnt...
Wait for me i'm coming to save you
c'est ça qu'on veut c'est ça qu'on veut c'est une squad soudée qui s'écoute qui communiquent exactement comme on est en train de faire
il m'a fermé la porte au nez pendant que faisait un discours motivant c'est fous
les gars les gars les gars
Attend mais j'allais donner du shield et et sonts mooorts!!! j'vais les venger
WAAAAOUH
WAAAAAAAOUH
Voilà c'est pour ça que je ferais plus de gaming
c'est qu'à chaque fois que j'en fais la fin est décevant la finalité est décevante et nul et nul!!!
a chaques fois... je remets ma seconde peau
Vous voyez comme j'ai l'air minable c'est VOTRE FAUTE
voilà pourquoi je ne fais plus de gaming car j'ai moins de plaisir à jouer aux jeux vidéo car je suis moins bon qu'avant tout
simplement car j'ai moins envie de jouer c'est un cercle vicieux
est-ce que cette phrase a du sens ? Je ne sais pas, analysez la, faites une vidéo "Réponse à Squeezie" Vous analisez cette phrase
C'est un bon moyen de faire des vues. Putain mais sur 10 games... pas un top1
avant je faisais 3 games j'avais 1 top 1. La je fais 10 games j'ai même pas un copain.
allez c'est chiant on met fin la vidéo maintenant
Je pars dans un trou en cassant le sol et ciao!
[bruit d'effondrement]
[en feu]
[musique d'outro]
n’hésitez pas a rectifier les sous titres si vous voyez des fautes! merci <3
sous titres français: Jade C ou Izuko (comme vous préférer ) et Noa C.
[musique d'outro]